I'm not bullish on California. And that ain't me.
I've talked to some very smart people who are economic animals and all of
them agree, and all of them are looking to get out because it's too expensive.
Why? Well, I live in on skid row, basically. I'm in Venice.
I've been in Venice for twenty-five years. I love it,
but I don't recognize my town anymore as much. And you know,
it's gotten really bad over there, right? It's not just gotten very bad.
It's become profitable because developers now can get these
government contracts. I mean, I can build you.
I can build you a bunch of apartments for $200 million on prime,
real estate on a parking lot. And on the beach, if you'd like,
I'd be happy to do that. And we can just have, we can create a homeless, uh, um,
apartments people for, for people who are homeless and, uh,
don't worry about doing drugs or anything else.
We're not gonna put any of those restrictions on you can come and go as you
like, you know? So, so there is something that see,
this is not me, but a scholar. I had a long conversation with called the,
the homeless industrial complex.
Once there's money in bidding and getting,
uh, homeless shelters for big developers, you better be careful.
All right. We talked about New York city.
We talked about Afghanistan seems like the segway to where we're
at right now in California.
What do you make about what's going on with this state? We, we both,
we talked about it about a month ago on your show.
I was strongly considering leaving. Like I was looking at real estate.
I had to hold a bunch of people begging me to come to Dallas.
I would have had a pretty sweet operation over there. Yeah.
My feeling right now is I want to stay in fight here. I love so Cal.
I love, you know, I love the weather of course and all that,
but like I built a good life here. We've got friends. I like it here.
It's a freaking mess. Absolute mess.
I think you were at a bit of a similar situation.
I, I didn't think about staying in fighting until I spoke to you and I've not,
I haven't stopped thinking about that. And I think you're right. Um,
I was just in Austin looking at property and boy does that. Ugh.
I know we probably, I told you,
you were probably looking at the same houses I'm on truly like, man,
when I can get in Austin.
Normally I can save. It's cheaper to live. It's the, you know,
I don't pay that 13% tax or whatever it is or 18%. Um, so yeah,
I could save a lot of money and um, what's happening in California.
It seems as businesses are leaving for just that reason,
because it's very expensive to do business here.
What California has going forward is a very diversified economy and amazing
weather. Um, and it's just a huge, important state for a lot of reasons.
But California was the state that worked and we have a
democratic super majority. And uh,
if you look at local POL politics, it's, it's just,
anytime you have a super majority of any group,
I don't care if it's Republican Democrat.
I don't think that's good for democracy. Um, your vote,
if you are someone who leans even a little bit, right? Doesn't count, save it,
stay home. We don't care. And you aren't getting elected to local office.
You're not getting elected to, to government office. You're not,
unless you are a pro big union across the board. Good luck,
good luck otherwise. And I'm a member of a union I'm in stag.
So I understand the value of unions, but
it's expensive to do business.
And unless you can push back a little bit or come up with a compromise, I don't,
I don't, I'm not bullish on California. And that ain't me.
I've talked to some very smart people who are economic animals and all of
them agree. And all of them are looking to get out because it's too expensive.
Why what I live in on skid row, basically I'm in Venice.
I've been in Venice for 25 years. I love it,
but I don't recognize my town anymore as much. And you know,
it's gotten really bad over there, right? It's not just gotten very bad.
It's become profitable because developers now can get these
government contracts. I mean, I can build you.
I can build you a bunch of apartments for $200 million on prime real estate on a
parking lot. And on the beach, if you'd like, I'd be happy to do that.
Then we can just have, we can create a homeless, uh, um,
apartments people for, for people who are homeless and, uh,
don't worry about doing drugs or anything else.
We're not gonna put any of those restrictions on.
You can come and go as you like. You know? So, so there is something that,
see, this is not me, but a scholar. I had a long conversation with called the,
the homeless industrial complex.
Once there's money in bidding and getting,
uh, homeless shelters for big developers, you better be careful.
So these people need to be put in treatment.
And the majority of the people on the street, it's not a housing problem.
It's not a housing problem. It's not a housing problem.
It is a mental health and addiction problem.
And until we get serious about that, uh, we're, we're,
we're going to be in big trouble.
Is it weird to you watching it spread in different areas?
So Venice always had a certain amount of that. Now it's definitely more,
but like Hollywood,
which also always had a certain amount it's like kind of taken over Hollywood.
If you just go to straight up,
especially now where there aren't as many other people on the streets. Now,
it just seems like all there are kind of like transient people and homeless and
tents and well, and as that inches closer to West Hollywood now,
and it'll Lynch closer to Beverly Hills and that, that then is my back.
Then it gets pushed.
Yeah. Well, you know, they have their own police force, but yeah,
prop 47 and you can't, it's not criminalized. There are all kinds of these.
I voted for prop 47 because the way it was phrased and it had the, it had the,
again on the ballot I'm as I'm voting, I went, well, this makes sense.
I don't want kids to be in a revolving door of crime and police chiefs back it.
And did you read the whole thing? I didn't that's I didn't have time.
I am remiss, but that's how they get you in this state.
I think more than any other during the last election,
there was this one thing on the ballot about, um, you know, do you want it,
it was something like this. Do you want to put $500 million, uh,
into education for, you know, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then there's essay just a giant, crazy essay on the whole thing.
And I skipped all the way to the bottom. And on the bottom, it says,
this can only be repealed or reversed by popular vote,
but nobody ever says, okay, now we'll take the money from the kids,
but that's government one Oh one,
he sell it exactly the packaging thing you're talking about.
Nobody reads the fine print.
And then you throw it back on the people to be like, Oh,
you'll have to take care of this.
There's always blow back. There's always a ripple effect. You bet.
No matter what the intentions are, you know,
we've spent something like $3 trillion on programs for the poor.
How's that going? How's it going? You know, it, it, it's very difficult.
I think at the end of the day, it's not about right or left.
You got to ask yourself,
do you really think that a bloated bureaucracy called the federal government is
the first line of defense? Is that the best way to solve these problems?
Is it I don't, I don't, I don't think so.
Is government going to keep families intact is a government official or a
bureaucrat who studies family law or whatever, going to keep your family intact.
Are they gonna, are they gonna get you to take care of your kids?
Are they going to get you the skill set you need in the 21st century?
The ever-changing 21st century? I it's a question. Yeah.
Maybe the answer is yes. In some cases,
but I don't know if that's always the question, the answer.
And you've got to ask those questions. The problem we run into is we go, well,
I'm a Republican, I'm a Democrat. I'm left. I'm right there.
There's nothing to hold on. Hold on. Let's let's go into,
what percentage of your money do you want to give the government? Every year,
every day I pay something like 52% in taxes.
So half my day,
half my year is working for someone else half my day,
half my year is working for someone else. So how much more do you want from me?
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're both right over here.
Had to get notified of all future videos.
Be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.